bonsoir nous sommes le mercredi 27
janvier merci de nous retrouver pour
cette nouvelle édition de 7,8 le journal
tout de suite les titres de votre
édition l'agglomération de versailles
grand parc s'agrandit cette année
vélizy-villacoublay rejoint cette
intercommunalité désormais formés de 19
communes pour 270 mille habitants thomas
bayer est un jeune comédien et
réalisateur atteints de la mucoviscidose
élèves au cours florent
il vient de finir son premier court
métrage faux semblants rencontre avec
celui le prussien et enfin à l'occasion
du festival de la bande dessinée
d'angoulême focus sur ce secteur de la
littérature en plein essor ainsi que sur
ses auteurs et mardi les taxis se sont
mobilisés contre la concurrence est
d'éviter ces véhicules de transport avec
chauffeur aujourd'hui la mobilisation a
été reconduite pour certains syndicats
elle va être reconduite plus longtemps
pour vous en parler ce soir michel
creton administrateurs syndicat des
taxis des épines bonsoir hamon merci
d'avoir accepté notre invitation à leur
manuel valls a proposé une concertation
un médiateur doit être nommé pourtant le
mouvement a continué tu peux nous en
dire un peu plus oui bah c'est très
simple en fait
aujourd'hui le fait que manuel valls
renomme qu'un conciliateur
enfin s'il ne fait que retarder encore
un peu plus le règlement de ce problème
là et en fait c'est pas avec la maison à
négociateurs qu'on va s'en sortir donc
aujourd'hui la problématique des taxis
et et prennent vraiment vraiment très
très grave
et en fait il faut prendre des mesures
des mesures vraiment braconniers et je
veux dire le milieu le médiateur n'est
pas un débat une solution en soi des
mesures ce sont vraiment de faire
appliquer la loi donc il ya une loi qui
a été qui a été promulguée en fin 2014
sur le qui organise la le travail entre
les taxis et les vtc et ça clôt
aujourd'hui n'est pas appliquée donc on
demande à l'étang effectivement de
l'appliquer tout simplement donc c'est
pas un négociateur qui va
il va faire ça donc il faut être avais
je dire certains de mes de mes camarades
vont même plus loin puisqu'ils veulent
doivent ils demandent la disparition
pure et simple des vtc la société en
france a été condamnée à verser 1,2
million d'euros de dommages-intérêts à
l'hymne national les taxis l'information
est aujourd'hui ce n'est pas suffisant
pour vous il faut aller plus loin
oui il faut aller beaucoup plus loin
parce qu'en fait aujourd'hui si vous
voulez le les les taxis qui sont des
chefs d'entreprises dont qui sont des
artisans
aujourd'hui on des baisses de chiffre
d'affaires qui sont de l'ordre de 50% ce
qui est énorme et doivent lutter
aujourd'hui contre des transporteurs qui
qui payent la moitié moins de charges
donc vous donner une idée aujourd'hui un
taxi paye à peu près 50% de charge un
vtc paye 25% donc déjà on est parent
légal
et là je vous parle des vtc légaux
puisqu'il ya encore un autre type de vie
de deux transporteurs qui sont les
illégaux donc ce qu'on appelait
autrefois est des taxis clandestins et
qui pénalise énormément ce marché là et
ce qui fait qu'aujourd'hui on se
retrouve par exemple dans pour l'autre
département les yvelines avec un certain
nombre de taxis parisiens qui n'ayant
plus de travail sur paris vienne le
prendre dans leur région et dans le
notamment sur le temps la grande
couronne et notamment sur le son les
yvelines donc nous avions à tourner un
reportage justement sur cette
mobilisation avec vous il n'y a pas eu
d'accident mais plusieurs incidents ont
eu lieu hier
on recense un blessé vingt quatre
interpellations en ile de france
des violences qui ont été condamnés par
manuel valls est ce que ça va quand même
trop loin vous comprenez que les gens
puissent être choqués je comprends très
bien je veux dire c'est pour nous c'est
même ces mêmes jeunes et on est choqué
par ça parce que c'est pas du tout le
l'objectif qu'on s'était fixés lorsqu'on
on a fait cette grève cette grave
d'ailleurs celle que nous avons mené de
ce département a été beaucoup plus
beaucoup plus calme et on n'a pas le
droit de le dire demain de manifester et
d'avoir aidé à voir des gestes de
violence ça n'arrive à rien et c'est pas
comme ça qu'on fait avancer les choses
et ça nous on condamne fortement ce
mouvement-là qui en plus de ça je veux
dire aujourd'hui sur on a une image du
taxi qui est relativement dégradée et
qui se retrouve encore plus dégradée
donc je dis on est on est tout à fait
contre en ce
on vit on ne veut absolument pas que ça
se renouvelle donc c'est aussi une des
raisons pour laquelle on n'a pas
continué notre mouvement mais aussi en
comprend très bien ce qui le qu'il
continue parce que aujourd'hui il faut
qu'on aille jusqu'au bout de notre
démarche c'est d'aider et de ce que l'on
demande au gouvernement
mais d'un autre côté il faut qu'on le
fasse aussi dans des conditions qui
soient respectueuses du bon
fonctionnement et notamment de ne pas de
ne pas pénaliser non plus les usagers au
bout d'un certain temps je vais aller
les âges et je sais par exemple au d un
exemple de d'hier les gens que nous et
qui nous doubler lorsque nous faisions
le ralentissement sur le sur l'a13 à
nous insulter mais je dois parce qu'ils
ne connaissent pas ou parce que parce
qu'ils vont arriver en retard etc
mais ce qu'ils ne se quittent oublie
c'est que incertain de l'entreprise
aujourd'hui vont se retrouver dans des
difficultés financières énormes voir à
déposer des bilans ce que ce qui ce qui
est complètement je veux dire aberrant
dans une économie où où normalement on
devrait vivre vert au moins de manière
correcte mais ce qui n'est pas du tout
pas du tout le cas
le nom fait syndicat des taxis devils
est l'administrateur apprécié sa
mobilisation d'autres syndicats vont là
continuer ce que la profession peut se
mettre d'accord justement face à ce
groupe c'est ça c'est l'eau c'est un peu
la gueule la grosse problématique
aujourd'hui du syndicat fans des des
syndicats du taxi je veux dire aux miens
on a un métier qui est un petit peu un
métier unique enfin je veux dire qu'on
soit taxi à marseille à paris ou encore
paris c'est un petit peu différent mais
entre je dire toutes les dents les taxis
vous avez les taxis parisiens qui ont
une façon de fonctionner qui est un peu
différente de tous les autres taxis il
devrait y avoir qu'un seul syndicat je
vous dis aujourd'hui on devrait être
tous unis
main dans la main pour pouvoir demander
ce que l'on a demandé 100
alors qu'aujourd'hui on est on est
vraiment morcelé on est divisé on n'est
pas d'accord sur les chemins pentagone
et ça c'est nous aujourd'hui on le
regrette force enfin en tout cas moi
personnellement je le regrette fortement
merci beaucoup mais chaque run avoir
répondu à nos questions et ils ont cru
que ça sur notre plateau fois sans
transition la communauté d'agglomération
de versailles grand parc s'agrandit
seule nouveauté cette année c'est la
commune de vélizy villacoublay qui a
fait son entrée au 1er janvier dernier
plus proche des hauts-de-seine lorsque
la commune était dans l'agglomération du
grand paris seine ouest vélizy entend
désormais se rapprocher de son coeur
historique et géographique la ville de
versailles
les précisions de fanny bourdillon est
une commune de plus velizy villacoublay
à intégrer au 1er janvier 2016
versailles grand parc
l'agglomération compte désormais 19
communes et 270 mille habitants la ville
dispose d'un bassin économique dynamique
sa vitalité en fera un atout fort pour
la communauté d'agglomération les
conséquences sont positives à la fois
pour les villes de versailles grand parc
et pour vélizy pour vélizy le bénéfice
c'est d'intégrer une communauté qui a
une identité forte qui ait connu pourra
avoir un climat de travail très
constructif où chaque maire a vraiment
la possibilité de s'exprimer
et puis pour verse un grand parc c'est
l'occasion donc de compléter une
amic culturelle évidente parce que
versailles grand parc est connue aussi
pour la qualité de vie et une dynamique
économique est plus marquée pour baliser
la ville étaient rattachés encore il ya
un an à l'agglomération grand paris
seine ouest
mais pour le maire de vélizy c'était
naturel que la ville se tourne vers une
agglomération 100% yvelinoise le bassin
de vie de vélizy et tournée vers
versailles 1 puisque les lycéens avant à
versailles et toute la vie fait la 118
est une barrière par rapport aux
habitants donc nous on est vraiment
tourné vers versailles grand parc et
puis on a même un syndicat entre jouer
et vélizy qui gère une base de loisirs
avec beaucoup d'activités sportives
culturelles et artistiques
avec cette décision le maire entend
échapper à la métropole du grand paris
que vélizy aurait dû rejoindre si elle
était restée dans l'agglomération du
grand paris seine ouest
elle s'y était engagée élue présidente
de l' île de france valérie pécresse a
démissionné de son poste de député déi
viennent
c'est maintenant la question de sa
succession qui se posent dans la 2e
circonscription
la date du scrutin n'est pas encore
connue mais les républicains ont désigné
déjà leur candidat pascal thévenot le
maire de vélizy villacoublay
proche de l'ancien ministre élu à la
tête de cette commune en mars 2014
il était en concurrence avec ivan nova
l'actuel suppléant de la députée
ce dernier sera à la tête de son comité
de soutien a écouté je pense que député
maire de vélizy c c'est un poste
passionnant où et où je pense que je
fais tous les jours aussi bien quand je
suis en contact les grands chefs
d'entreprises qui sont ici ou avec mes
citoyens
finalement il ya on s'aperçoit que la
vraie vie aller sur le terrain et qu'il
ya beaucoup de
mesure législative à faire évoluer et
puis ça te permettra aussi d'avoir un
député un peu différent qui viennent du
monde de l'entreprise et qui porte un
peu tout ce qui est l'innovation tout ce
qui est fils qualité pour que cela soit
puni simplement une contrainte ou une
vue purement étatique mais que ça vienne
un peu des forces vives et face à lui il
devrait retrouver son opposant
socialiste au conseil municipal
amorosa duvar ce dernier attend
l'investiture de son parti mais il a
déjà lancé sa campagne en reprochant au
candidat des républicains de vouloir
cumuler les mandats
pascal thévenot et est également vice
président chargé du développement
économique à versailles grand parc comme
vous avez pu le voir dans le sujet
précédent et après une semaine
d'élections pour nouveau conseil
municipal des jeunes de trappes
les résultats ont été divulgués hier
soir en salle du conseil de la commune
les sept trappistes âgés de 12 à 16 ans
tiendront leur première assemblée
plénière le samedi 6 février pour
définir leurs priorités fixées leurs
thèmes et arrêter les actions
nécessaires qui souhaitent mettre en
place
ils siègeront pendant deux ans c'est
important pour la ville de trappes donc
il montre l'exemple dans l'exercice de
la citoyenneté
il montre l'exemple dans l'engagement il
montre l'exemple dans la représentation
auprès de leurs pairs j'ai envie de dire
les jeunes ils ont une place aussi dans
aider les jeunes et je vais essayer de
faire mon possible
ouais c'est très bien le concéder jeunes
franchement c'est une très belle
expérience
on apprend de nouvelles choses on
organise des événements plein de choses
et le marathon à des voeux du mois de
janvier se poursuivait lundi soir à la
ferme du manet de montigny le bretonneux
mais celle logis en a profité pour
saluer la victoire de valérie pécresse
aux élections régionales ils espèrent
beaucoup de cette nouvelle la majorité
pour faire évoluer le réseau de
transport quelques bonnes nouvelles pour
la ville enfin malgré une baisse de
dotation générale de fonctionnement de
plus d'un million d'euros montigny le
bretonneux reste la ville de plus de
20000 habitants la moins endettée des
yvelines seconde bonne nouvelle des
terrains de sport seront aménagés sur
l'emprise du prolongement de la a12 et
nous allons parler cinéma
à présent nous recevons thomas bayer
bonsoir sur vous alors thomas veillet
vous êtes originaire de villepreux
vous êtes comédiens au cours florent et
vous venez de sortir votre premier court
métrage faux semblants nous allons en
parler telle que dans quelques instants
avant je vous propose de regarder un
extrait j'ai de nouveau pressé de quoi
tu parles
c'est bien d'avoir un enfant tous les
deux céline on va pas remettre ça
on a essayé pendant six ans il n'y a pas
de raison qu'on n'arrive plus
aujourd'hui
regarde le résultat on s'est fait plus
de mal que de bien c'est que des
contraintes et plus aucun plaisir parce
que l'enjeu n'en vaut pas la peine non
et si on essayait l'adoption arrête
l'adoption c'est une procédure longue on
va pas voir un gamin à 50 ans il faut
que tu passe à autre chose que je passe
à autre chose ça veut dire quoi ça
alors vous n'êtes pas comédien dans ce
court métrage vous êtes uniquement le
réalisateur c'est une histoire de couple
comment vous est venue l'idée de ce
sujet pourquoi l'avoir traité c'est pas
compliqué en fait je suis rentré l'année
dernière en deuxième année
cinéma au cours florent et j'ai eu la
chance de rencontrer un comédien qui est
devenu un ami harry cloche
et à l'époque qui me parlait d'une pièce
de théâtre qu'ils étaient en train de
jouer dans sa classe parallèle qui était
l'amant d'aral pinto et j'ai trouvé
l'histoire fabuleuse franchement j'ai
adoré et je vais tout de suite dit
écoute ce serait pas super d'en faire un
film un court métrage et bien sûr voilà
je vais proposer tout de suite de jouer
dedans et on a commencé à écrire en fait
sur sur ce sujet on est parties du
squelette de la pièce est ensuite au fur
et à mesure on sentait un peu écartée et
pour trouver notre histoire
donc là vous avez vous êtes réalisateur
sur ce projet c'est difficile de passer
du statut de comédien à ceux des
réalisateurs en fait je pense que écrire
c'est comme jouer c'est à dire que il ya
un parallèle qui se fait automatiquement
et et pour ça l'écriture on s'imagine en
fait en train de jouer moi même je me
suis imaginé à la place des deux acteurs
eric aussi et ça nous permet d'écrire
donc finalement il n'y a pas tellement
de différence entre les deux métiers
donc le court métrage voilà et va être
diffusé vendredi prochain le but c'est
de le faire connaître
qu'ils fassent le tour des festivals
simple objectif c'est ça donc l'objectif
nous on propose vendredi soir une sortie
à une projection privée
donc il ya 250 personnes à paris ça va
être l'occasion pour moi et pour les
comédiens de
de se jauger un petit peu de savoir où
on en est de notre parcours et donc
ensuite on va prendre la température et
suivant les les rebondissements et c'est
ben je tenterai certes un festival au
cours de l'année et l'année prochaine
alors ce n'est pas votre premier projet
vous ayez fait déjà un premier court
métrage mais qui était un petit peu plus
court il traitait notamment de la
mucoviscidose énergétique qui touche 2
millions de personnes en france et
s'appelait mille printemps je pense
qu'on va pouvoir est possible un petit
des images a qui vont à défiler pourquoi
vous hésité à investir dans ce projet
justement à titre personnel parce
qu'effectivement mois étant touchés de
près et atteint par cette maladie
je me suis posé la question de savoir
comment j'allais pouvoir transmettre un
message à ces gens sans parler de ma vie
à moi c'est à dire que déjà pour une
simple raison c'est que je trouve ça
très narcissique que je pense pas que ça
intéresse grand monde la vie de thomas
payet mais parce ce clip ce premier clip
je me suis dit je vais en fait
représenter ces personnes qui acceptent
de vivre l'amour avec quelqu'un de
malade alors dans ce cas là c'est la
mucoviscidose mais ce film pour aller à
n'importe quelle différence et n'importe
quelle maladie
c'est un sujet c'est un sujet c'est un
message fort dont vous tenez à parler on
a un peu parlé talent dans le dans
l'autre
court métrage d'une faux semblants c'est
la difficulté d'avoir des enfants de ne
pas avoir d enfant et vous me disiez que
c'était également un problème qu'on
était atteint cette maladie
effectivement de toute façon lorsqu'on
écrit une histoire ou conte choisi un
rôle c'est pour y mettre un morceau de
sois dedans sinon c'est pas la peine
donc effectivement temps faux semblants
je raconte effectivement que il peut
être difficile
pas impossible mais difficile d'avoir
des enfants et je dirais pas que c'est
une thérapie d'avoir fait ce film parce
que un acteur ne fait pas de thérapie
ans dans ses films ou alors ils en
parlent pas mais ça permet peut-être que
certaines personnes se retrouvent en
fait dans ses films et c'est qu'ils ne
sont pas seuls à vivre la même chose et
que l'on peut toujours trouver des
solutions alors dans faux semblants on
était allé chercher quand même loin
c'est à dire que c'est pas quelque chose
qui pourrait arriver un couple dans la
vie de tous les jours mais il ya
toujours des solutions et le principe
c'est de se battre et dirigé qu'elle va
être un peu la suite pour le court
métrage est ce qu'on aura peut être la
chance de pouvoir le voir dans les
yvelines
bah écoutez je dois discuter avec la
ville de plaisir pour voir si une
proposition apparemment au mois de juin
festival du court métrage
donc pourquoi pas
lancée le court métrage dans cette
compétition voilà vous aurez peut-être
la chance d'avoir un faux semblant prêt
stival du court métrage de péter
remercie beaucoup thomas bayer des
douaniers en plateau mais vont devoir
accepter notre invitation et tout autre
sujet à présent c'est le retour des
épidémies hivernales la grippe mais
aussi la gastro entérite mercredi 20
janvier le réseau de surveillance
sentinelles composé de 1300 médecins
généralistes libéraux annoncé que le
seuil épidémique de la gastro entérite
et ait été atteint en france
métropolitaine
ce seuil est à linthes atteint lorsque
193 personnes sont malades pour 100000
habitants la semaine dernière la france
étaient encore concernés puisqu'il y
avait 247 cas pour 100000 habitants du
docteur fleury médecins à quoi lumière
nous en explique les raisons
la première manière de s'en prémunir
c'est justement une des mesures de
protection par rapport à ça des mesures
d'hygiène c'est le mot cardinal par
rapport à la gastro et dans la toute
première mesure pour s'en protéger
c'est tout banalement le lavage des
mains de lavage donc bien bien soigneux
le brassage disons-le etc
le virus ça s'appelle à rotavirus est
assez banal et donc mais qui très
résistant et donc ils résistent assez
facilement à l'extérieur de l'organisme
et donc ni aux mines il a le temps de se
transmettre et santé toujours avez vous
entendu parler de la sono thérapie ses
deux fils médecines alternatives qui
existent depuis le 16e siècle mais qui
reste encore méconnu aujourd'hui la
sonotone sono thérapie 71 techniques de
bien-être par le massage sonore est une
méthode de soins sont s'est rééquilibré
la circulation d'énergie dont le corps
en utilisant les sons williams elle a
rencontré david baconnais sono
thérapeute à fontenay le fleury
il vous en dit plus sur cette pratique
où
reposant à l'ecoute se sont n'est
pourtant pas destiné à vos oreilles mais
à votre cerveau et vos organes david
backes connaissons nos thérapeutes
il utilise les sous pour équilibrer la
circulation d'énergie dans le corps
c'est une technique qui aident à
retrouver l'équilibré pour une meilleure
santé morale une meilleure santé
physique tout le travail de la sono
thérapie se trouvait la vibration
approprié pour harmoniser les vibrations
pour qu'il n'y ait plus de 10 à rooney
pour retrouver l'équilibré
une méthode thérapeutique qui agit au
temps sur le psyché que sur le physique
pour soigner le stress par exemple david
hughes lycée bol tibétain
ap les bols chantants on a tous une
énergie qu'on dégage d'une façon plus ou
moins large et donc les vols qui seront
sept métaux chacun des métaux va va
vibrer plus ou moins cependant selon
l'état énergétique de la personne moi
j'aime me résumer ça en dix ans selon
les creux et les bosses votre méthode
utilisée celle des diapasons ici david
parle de méridien comme une sorte
d'acupuncture sonore chaque note
correspond un point particulier musicien
qui a mis en place sa technique des
diapasons qui est fabien maman a trouvé
une note pour chaque dire qu'ils ont
donc de la même façon on la met en
vibration et on va le poser sur la main
sur le point qui est intéressant pour la
personne
voilà la sensation que j'avais c'était à
la fois d'être pris en charge et en même
temps d'avoir vraiment une direction
chaque chaque son chaque sensation comme
ça à chaque son avait avait une vraie
volonté et ça ça m'a surpris en fait
même si la sono thérapie reste une
médecine douce non reconnue par
l'académie de médecine
plusieurs études ont déjà mis en avant
l' influence des sons et des fréquences
sur les organes et à partir de jeudi et
jusqu'au 31 janvier à angoulême c'est le
43e festival de la bande dessinée grand
rendez-vous du 9e art l'année 2016 a été
un très bon cru avec 39 millions
d'albums vendus mélanie poker s'est
intéressé à ce sujet bonsoir melanie
south emploie alors vous l'avez dit 39
millions d'albums vendus
ça représente 450 9 millions d'euros en
2015 plus de 5000 livres ont été publiés
dont 3924 sont de strictes nouveautés il
y en a pour tous les goûts la bd
jeunesse elle la bd historique
l'éternel bd franco-belge et celle pour
adultes qui prend de plus en plus
d'ampleur dans l'édition
je suis allé aux pavés du canal qui est
à montigny le bretonneux demandé à
laurent guérin responsable de la
librairie pourquoi ça plaît autant il ya
plusieurs choses en fait c'est souvent
le dessin alors après on peut dans l'art
roman graphique c'est aussi les sujets
traités parce que ces voix là on arrive
a dit vraiment diversifier les domaines
le champ du possible finalement donc
vraiment c'est ça qui est aussi
intéressant et
et le fait qu' il arrive aussi à se
renouveler enfin voilà alors en 2014
c'était le dernier blake et mortimer
mortimer qui est arrivé en tête avec 2
132 mille exemplaires et pour l'année
2015 qu'en est il je pense florennes que
vous ne saurez pas surprise c'est un
célèbre gaulois qui arrive sur la
première place du podium pour les 2015
le papyrus de césar les 36e aventures
d'astérix se sont vendus à plus d'un
million six cent mille exemplaires il
est même l' ouvrage le plus vendu en
france sur l'année
qu'est ce qui vous plaît autant les
réponses le fait de pouvoir se plonger
dans un univers complètement différent
du quotidien vraiment sortir du
quotidien sont pas mal orchestrée par le
dessinateur je trouve et puis les
scénarios un peu sympa il est petit
mystère qui sont bien quoi voilà le fait
que tout peu une idée peut plus rentrer
beaucoup plus facilement par par l'image
et le dialogue
j'aime beaucoup l'art ce n'est fait en
ce moment le mec qui me plaît bien c'est
riad sattouf ça c'est les deux auteurs
en ce moment que j'apprécie dis donc il
ya de nombreux fans de bd alors lors du
festival d'angoulême de nombreux prix
sont remis et la sélection a connu des
remous cette année après l'absence de
femmes auteures et cela un petit pas
fait polémique
on en a beaucoup parlé alors faut
préciser c'est en fait la sélection du
grand prix qui a provoqué des remous
le grand prix c'est une sorte de césar
d'honneur sa récompense la carrière d'un
auteur à l'issue de la polémique la
direction du festival a finalement
décidé de ne pas faire de sélection et
de laisser le monde de la bd choisir
celle ou celui qu'elle veut récompenser
il ya aussi le fauve d'or là c'est le
prix du meilleur album
cette année quarante albums sont en
concurrence
le mieux c'est d'écouter long hangar 1
il nous donne son avis sur la sélection
alors la sélection du fauve d'or cette
année pour nous elle est vraiment très
intéressante parce qu'elle ouvre
vraiment à tous les domaines de la bd
donc il ya du franco-belge a aussi du
comics avec outkast encore ils couvrent
vraiment tous les domaines et c'est dans
ce sens où l'on voit vraiment que la
production et énergique est intéressante
parce qu'on a vraiment tout le panel de
la bd qui représentait dans cette
sélection
alors est ce qu'on a le droit à un avis
d'expert laurent gare à vous at il
confié qu'ils étaient ses favoris ses
favoris pour le grand prix le coup de
coeur du pavé du canal c'est alan moore
il est assez
connu surtout pour v pour vendetta s'est
adapté au cinéma avec natalie portman et
le masque du personnage principal est
devenue le symbole des anonymous pour le
fauve d'or leur choix va vers cher pays
de notre enfance d'étienne davodeau et
benoît collombat c'est un documentaire
dessinée qui revient sur l'histoire
contemporaine du sac
le service d'ordre du parti gaulliste
pour voir si leur gardien et son équipe
ont eu du flair pour le grand prix
florane c'est dès ce soir il faut bien
sûr d'actualité pour le fauve d'or
rendez-vous la fin du festival
merci beaucoup mélanie et
malheureusement il n'a pas d'auteur
yvelines ouah ça sera notre grand regret
vous nous suivrons quand même à cette
actualité c'est la fin de cette émission
je vous remercie de nous avoir suivis
rester avec nous dans quelques minutes
vous avez rendez vous avec sephora
namani pour un hymne au nouveau numéro
de kiosque votre magazine culturel quant
à moi je vous retrouve demain pour une
nouvelle édition du journal je vous
souhaite donc une excellente soirée